bruno retailleau le nouveau président du
groupe ump au sénat est l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous donc pour ce rendez-vous de
public sénat avec dailymotion et avec l'
agence france-presse représenter ce soir
par guillaume daudin bien avec lui tout
à l'heure nous parlerons de la
compétition qui s'aiguisent à l'ump en
vue de 2017 et puis nous ferons plus
ample connaissance avec vous à la fin de
ce journal est avec perrine tarneaud
votre vos combats votre parcours un
engagement d'ailleurs tout récent à
l'ump on verra ça donc avec perrine tout
à l'heure d'abord bruno retailleau les
nouvelles pistes d'économies pour les
allocations familiales il y aura une
modulation partiel c'est la piste donc
qui a été retenue par les députés ps en
accord semble-t-il avec le gouvernement
ainsi la fin de la majoration à partir
de 15 ans pour les enfants des ménages
les plus aisés comment est-ce que vous
réagissez à ce que la gauche présente
comme une mesure de justice et d'équité
moi je ne comprends pas du tout cette
obsession anti famille de la gauche ça
me dépasse
dès qu'il faut des mesures c'est sûr les
familles qu'on tape on ad'abord
matraquer fiscalement les familles et
désormais on voudrait les étrangler ce
que je voudrais dire bien sûr
financièrement ce que je voudrais dire
très simplement c'est que le déficit de
la branche famille il est dû à une chose
c'est que c'est la branche famille est
ponctionnée hauteur de plus de 4
milliards d'euros pour les régimes de
retraite première chose deuxième chose
s'il ya quelque chose qui fonctionne
bien en france c'est justement la
politique familiale qui nous permet
d'avoir une natalité une démographie qui
est dynamique n'oublions jamais que ce
qu'on appelle la croissance potentielle
dépend de la démographie de demain et
l'allemagne d'aujourd'hui commence à
l'éprouver parce qu' elle n'a pas le
même taux de natalité est donc on a un
indicateur qui fonctionne bien en france
la natalité et on veut y mettre fin je
trouve que c'est extrêmement grave c'est
la fin de la politique avec une
dimension universelle de la famille on
confond deux choses
on confond une politique redistributive
qui est par essence la politique fiscale
avec une autre politique et la politique
familiale
mais je peux vous assurer que sur le
plan de l'emploi sur le plan économique
ce sera catastrophe mais on n en avait
la ministre de la santé marisol touraine
à votre place ici
il ya quinze jours elle disait qu'elle
ne voulait pas croire qu'on faisait des
enfants dans notre pays pour les
prestations sociales avère que nous sur
connu nous disait qu'elle ça n'aurait
aucune incidence sur la natalité bien
sûr que non mais il s'agit à niveau de
vie comparable
quand vous avez deux familles qui ont
l'une qui ont qu un enfant ou l'autre
qui vont avoir trois enfants
l'une qui a plusieurs enfants va
contribuer par exemple au régime de
répartition pour les retraites et c'est
normal
elle va subir une baisse de niveau de
vie c'est normal que la politique
familiale puisse compenser cette baisse
de niveau de vie
c'est un problème d'utilité publique et
j'ajoute politiquement que
malheureusement notre pacte républicain
c'est aussi la politique familiale
pourquoi parce que c'est le front
populaire
j'ai grossi au qui inventent les
allocations familiales
c'est général de gaulle qui invente le
quotient familial
donc il ya un consensus qui se fait sur
la famille aujourd'hui la gauche
brouille les repères casse les consensus
divise les français et en plus amène
l'économie française dans le trou noir
sur cette mesure la wii est une mesure
terrible sur le plan économique et sur
le plan de la justice familiale c'est
une mesure anti justice vraiment est ce
qu'on peut dire qu on assassine on
massacre la politique familiale en
voulant faire 700 millions d'économies
alors que le budget global beda la
natalité ses 60 milliards
mais pourquoi vouloir faire des
économies sur la famille pourquoi
vouloir faire des économies sur un
secteur qui fonctionne
voilà il ya tant d'autres économies on
attend du gouvernement qu'il fasse des
vraies économies notamment de politique
structurelle il ne les fait pas alors
effectivement le besoin d'économies il
est criant dans tous les secteurs bruno
retailleau la droite d'ailleurs promet
de faire deux fois mieux que le
gouvernement dans le bras de fer
qui est déjà amorcée d'ailleurs entre
paris et bruxelles sur le budget parce
que vous donnerez donc raison à
bruxelles mais d'abord je suis français
mais ce que je veux simplement dire au
gouvernement c'est que pour tenir son
rang à bruxelles
il faut tenir ses comptes en france et
là c'est une règle toute sa part et
affiche sa confiance face à bruxelles le
gouvernement a tort il a tort le
problème c'est que le gouvernement a
déjà pris des engagements françois
hollande souvenez-vous après plusieurs
engagements d'abord 2013 ensuite 2015
pour ramener les déficits à 3% est
extraordinaire c'est la première fois
depuis la crise des années 2008 2010
2009 le déficit en france cette année
sera supérieure aux déficits 2013 c'est
catastrophique pour la crédibilité
française donc je ne donne ni tort à
bruxelles je ne donne pas raison
gouvernement français quand on prend des
engagements qu'elles ont les tirs qu'on
les tient pas pour bruxelles on les
tient pour remettre en ordre les comptes
français parce que si on ne les remet
pas en ordre
on va dépendre de plus en plus
d'investisseurs notamment étrangers qui
détiennent notre dette et embarquement
fragiliser la france justement françois
fillon qui à votre soutien a évoqué
récemment le risque d'un accident
financier majeur pour notre pays qui est
qu'est ce qu'il a voulu dire
il veut il veut parler des taux
d'intérêt heureusement il y arrive alors
je me suis draghi mais d'une politique
est extrêmement mobile extrêmement
réactive à la tête de la banque centrale
européenne et les taux sont très bas
pourquoi les taux sont bas parce que
j'ai à cette politique européenne mais
aussi parce que il ya une déprime et
quand il ya peu de croissance
en règle générale les taux sont bas
simplement ce que voulait dire profusion
c'est que si jamais demain les taux
augmenté d'un point ça se répercuterait
sur la première année de 2 milliards 4
milliards on entrerait dans une spirale
grecque et ce serait très difficile à
maîtriser
heureusement nous ne sommes pas là
heureusement mais le moment de la
catastrophe
approche si le gouvernement français
continue de trahir ses engagements est
ce que en même temps vous reconnaissez
qu'il faut savoir ne pas aller trop loin
en matière d'économie parce que certains
économistes le disent qu'on pourrait
s'enfoncer un peu plus dans la récession
écoutez sur ce débat je pense qu'il faut
avoir les idées claires ce que fait
aujourd'hui le gouvernement
c'est des coups de rabot c'est une
politique à la petite semaine
il n'y a aucune vision d'ensemble il n'y
a pas de politique structurelle
aujourd'hui il faut changer de cadre par
exemple on sait parfaitement que pour
faire des économies
il faudra toucher à la masse salariale
de l'état pour avoir moins de
fonctionnaires il faudra pouvoir les
payer sans doute mieux mais ne pas les
remplacer tous pour le départ à la
retraite et pour le faire il fracasse et
je suis désolé la politique des 35
heures y compris dans la fonction
publique alors vous ne mentionnez pas
les collectivités locales
si joyeux alors c'est parce qu'elles
sont elles se font encore épinglé
aujourd'hui par la cour des comptes a
avec des dépenses de fonctionnement qui
ne cessent d'augmenter alors un les
collectivités locales doivent aussi être
associé à la fort à l'effort d'économie
générale à la baisse des dotations des
chocs c'est ce qui se passe avec la
baisse dans les yeux en attendait
simplement
simplement on en a marre que l'état au
moment même où il nous demande de faire
des économies se défausse sur nous je
prends un exemple les rythmes scolaires
c'est paris qui décide et c'est les
collectivités en bas qui paye et cet
exemple là je peux le x 10 michel
grossiord donc moi je dis chiche pour
des économies alors que l'état arrête de
nous transférer des charges des
nouvelles dépenses
ce que je voudrais dire aussi c'est que
des effectifs de fonctionnaires mais les
collectivités locales n'ont cessé
d'embaucher c'est ce que dénonce
t'accorder en tissu et notamment sur le
blog intercommunalités et les communes
donc je pense qu'il ya des efforts à
faire je pense que les certaines
collectivités ou les fonctionnaires ils
sont en dessous de 35 heures ça n'est
pas normal je pense que cette petite
cette politique 35 heures il fera la
revoir ce que je veux dire quand même
pour les collectivités c'est que les
collectivités n'ont pas la même dette
que l'état pourquoi parce que nous avons
la règle d'or
nous avons nous une interdiction écoutez
moi bien d'emprunter pour financer les
dépenses de fonctionnement c'est à dire
que notre dette et de la bonne date
c'est celle qui finance de
l'investissement si demain si demain
avec la baisse des dotations il ya plus
d'investissements des collectivités en
france
aura plus du tout d'investissement
public ce sera moins d'emplois ce sera
plus de chômage c'est clair alors elle
saute question faut-il réformer
l'assurance chômage des indemnités moins
généreuses ou moins longtemps
est ce que par exemple pour parler
franchement plus clairement vous êtes
sur la ligne valls macron non parce que
si l'on voit la ligne valse vaincrons
c'est une ligne ont déclaré besoin de
réforme de l'assurance chômage
ils ont pouvoir ils sont au gouvernement
mais pas que on attend on n'attend pas
d'eux qu'ils s'expriment qu'ils fassent
des déclarations
on attend d'eux des actes qu'ils
agissent bien sûr moi je suis je pense
qu'il ya une forme de préférence
française pour le chômage de masse ce
que je voudrais dire c'est que il ya un
double paradoxe qui est insupportable
d'un côté il ya des gens qui ne trouvent
pas d'emploi et ils veulent travailler
qu'on ne nous fasse pas croire que ce
sont tous des assistés c'est faux il ya
des brebis galeuses il faut le voir il
faut les sanctionner bien et d'autres
côté paradoxe c'est que il ya des
centaines de milliers d'emplois je sais
dans mon département qui n'arrivent pas
à trouver des chômeurs fin des gens pour
parce que ils sont pas suffisamment
qualifiés et c'est donc je pense qu'il
faudra sans doute revoir les modalités
d'indemnisation les modalités d'accès
etc
surtout il faut transformer les dépenses
passives d'indemnisation en dépenses
active et notamment pour former
justement les chômeurs parce que pour
moi c'est que là en matière de formation
il ya déjà une enveloppe de 20 milliards
et c'est ceux qui sont les mieux formés
qui en bénéficient c'est que j'avais ce
débat à droite entre le chef de l'état
qui dit réformer oui mais peut-être plus
tard pour certaines mesures comme
l'assurance
celle ci voulait pourquoi est ce qu'il
ya des couacs permanent avant monsieur
montebourg c'était un quad par mois
monsieur macron c'est un quad par
semaine quant à mme royal à chacune de
ses phrases pratiquement ça vient des
couacs
on parlera sans doute de l'écotaxe tout
simplement parce que on a un chef de
l'état qui est sans boussole qui n'a pas
de cas qui louvoie en permanence donc
ses ministres sont sérieux tu n'as pas
de clarifications depuis le dernier
remaniement départ de monsieur gbagbo en
notamment
non il ya cette politique de l'offre
mais elle est pour l'instant en paroles
et on attend les actes et ses multiples
couacs
c'est tout simplement parce que il ya
des zigzags il ya un mouvement et je
pense que les ministres sont souvent
perdus
l'abandon de l'écotaxe justement c'est
un couac aussi recelant vous d'abord
nous et quand vous vous rendez compte
que ça va coûter entre 1 et 2 milliards
aux français j'espère j'espère ce sera
pas des ménages qui vont payer puisque
on a deux centimes de plus pour le
gazole qui vont s'ajouter à la taxe
carbone qui était une taxe de 2 centimes
aussi mais c'est pendant finances auquel
est lié d'autoroute mais manifestement
c'est compliqué elle a été recadrée des
sur ségolène royal et notamment l été
recadré par le premier ministre sur la
gratuité des autoroutes et week-end vous
regardez c'était une unité évidemment
qui avait tout pour plaire
faut-il en rire en sourire ou en pleurer
un mot sur un texte qui fait consensus
maintenant bruno retailleau cci le béton
est arrivé d'ailleurs au sénat et vous
allez devant prononcer sur les mesures
pour contre l'embrigadement et le départ
des djihadistes française qu'il faut
aller plus loin dans ses mesures
présentées par le ministre d'intérieur
et aller vers une justice d'exception
comme l'a demandé par exemple et xavier
bertrand qui pense aux djihadistes qui
sont de retour et qui évidemment sont
tous lourd de danger moi en tout cas je
pense qu'il faut la plus grande fermeté
mais il doit y avoir toujours un
équilibre entre les libertés publiques
et vous savez que le sénat est très
attaché à la promotion des libertés
publiques
mais en même temps il faut des
dispositifs qui soit efficace simplement
ce n'est pas avec ce texte qu'on va
résoudre le problème il ya un problème
qui est posé d'intégration et même
d'assimilation pour ces générations à la
culture française comment est ce que
vous comprenez ce que vous analysez
cette séduction effectivement chez
certains d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup de
convertis on le voit parmi eux pour un
engagement islam et que si loin de des
valeurs c'est incroyable c'est vraiment
vous avez gt gt un des tout premiers
parlementaires à me rendre en irak à
erbil c'était au mois d'août et j'ai
recueilli un certain nombre de
témoignages qui était poignant de
chrétiens de iasi dit quand on pense que
l'état islamique
vent comme esclaves pour 250 $ au marché
de mossoul des jeunes femmes quand on
pense aux exactions crucifixion
décapitation éventration de femme
enceinte
mais comment comment peut-on en france
avoir une génération qui soit obnubilé
par par cette violence par cette
barbarie sur ce coup là question n'y en
ait pas de compris compréhension du
phénomène certains évoquent des experts
ou même des spécialistes de l'onu et met
en cause c'est le problème
une conséquence de l'exclusion sociale
non non j'ai écouté c'est pas un prêtre
d'exclusion sociale
il ya heureusement des gens qui sont en
difficulté et qui n'adoptent pas des
thèmes aussi radicaux ce n'est pas
possible je pense que il ya le problème
de la politique de migration schengen au
niveau européen en france une politique
d'assimilation à faire un problème une
réforme - d'assimilation c'est un long
terme souvent controversées sur les gens
préfèrent intégration pourquoi
l'intégration parce que l'intégration ça
débouche souvent sur le communautarisme
et bien je pense qu'il faut faire aimer
à ces jeunes la république française
la notion d'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes les femmes sont égales aux
hommes c'est on ne peut pas transiger là
dessus on ne peut pas faire cohabiter
une culture qui serait intégré mais qui
conserverait cette norme là c'est pas
possible
la fraternité aussi c'est important la
liberté voilà je pense que
l'assimilation de ces valeurs elle est
fondamentale c'est la conception même de
la république j'aurais simplement dire
que la république française c'est quoi
ce n'est pas la couleur de peau
ce n'est pas la confession ce n'est pas
l'origine sociale c'est simplement
d'aimer la france est simplement de se
retrouver dans ces valeurs là si on ne
s'y retrouve pas je suis désolé il ya un
problème et pas ce qu'on fait eh bien il
faut avoir une politique migratoire il
faut avoir des quotas il faut avoir une
réforme profonde du droit d'asile
il faut reprendre tout à zéro il faut
aussi une école qui fasse aimer
l'histoire française notre histoire il
faut en même temps promouvoir ces
valeurs qui sont de belles valeurs qui
sont pas des valeurs du passé mais qui
sont les valeurs de notre avenir
on doit leur rendre enfin guillaume
daudin de la sp valeur vos nombreux
indre maintenant pour évoquer la
compétition à l'ump un pour la
présidence du parti bien sûr et puis en
vue de la primaire de 2016 d'abord on va
voir comment alain juppé crée désormais
la surprise sondage après sondage samia
de sheer c'est un peu sa revanche
alain juppé l'homme qu'on disait fini en
2004 fait aujourd'hui figure de favori
pour la primaire ump
les derniers sondages lui donnent 12
pendent avance sur nicolas sarkozy
une course qui se joue pour l'instant
moins sur les programmes que sur la
personnalité et sur ce point alain juppé
a su changer son image d' homme austère
il est aujourd'hui dans une situation
dans laquelle nous c'est jamais trouvé
dans sa vie politique
en tout cas dans sa vie politique
nationale il roule pour lui pour la
première fois il peut être lieu mais je
pense que celle d'hiver et c'est pour ça
qu'il est à la fois claire plus drôle
pendant un moment et plus naturelle mais
c'est aussi et surtout le style juppé
qui séduit face à nicolas sarkozy jugé
hyperactif bling bling et surtout trop
clivant qu'alain gp2 le sentiment d'être
calme reposé d'avoir la stature d'homme
d'état et de donner le sentiment
également face à une france qui a le
sentiment d'être relativement divisés de
pouvoir rassembler assez fortement la
société française rassemblés et surtout
élargir au centre c'est l'autre clé du
succès juppé quand nicolas sarkozy
séduit davantage le noyau dur de l'ump
avec alain juppé on partage certains
engagements notamment sur les questions
écologiques depuis longtemps d'ailleurs
et
et de fait sur ce sujet là on est
absolument en phase après je n'ai pas à
juger au sein de l'ump qui sera
privilégiée par les uns ou par les
autres
mais en tout cas ce qui est clair c'est
qu'on a un vrai partage d'idées et de
valeurs sur les questions écologiques et
sur notre vision d'avenir de la société
si la montée en puissance d'alain juppé
fait de l'ombre à nicolas sarkozy
c'est aussi l'autre candidat françois
fillon qu'elle pénalise avant qu'alain
juppé monte en puissance
le duel annoncé ce que sarko et fillon
maintenant qu'il eut cette montée en
puissance annoncé çà sarkozy je paie
alors ces choses là peuvent encore
bouger mais la vraie difficulté pour
françois fillon à mon avis c'est que
françois fillon a pris un positionnement
très en pointe de thatchérisme à la
française ce positionnement est
minoritaire à l'intérieur même de la
droite mais françois fillon peut compter
sur le soutien d'une centaine de
parlementaires et nicolas sarkozy a
toujours la confiance des militants
mieux que personne
alain juppé c'est que les sondages
peuvent s'inverser d'ici 2016 voilà
guillaume de conserver vos questions à
bruno retailleau
bonsoir monsieur retailleau on vient de
voir dans les secondes dans le précédent
sujet donc il ya un certain nombre de
sondages qui commença à pencher en
faveur d'alain juppé a montré une
progression de sa part si vous avez
l'impression voit aussi que voilà il
progresse qu'il commence à être le la
personnalité numéro un à droite parfait
numéro un je ne sais pas mais il ya une
progression c'est clair pourtant les
sondages
est ce que vous vous souvenez à quel
niveau était françois hollande au début
de l'année 2011
à moins de 5% à 2% donc si vous voulez
c'est alors relativiser sondages
d'autant plus qu'il ya deux compétitions
la première compétition c'est la
compétition pour la présidence de l'ump
alain juppé ou françois fillon n'en sont
pas nicolas sarkozy en est puis ensuite
sur à l'autre compétition moi j'y suis
attaché les primaires qui devront
départager le candidat de droite et du
centre pour l'élection présidentielle de
alors il ya un élément qui est sur
lequel peut-être vous avez une analyse
c'est le retour de nicolas sarkozy brice
hortefeux a parlé d'un retour réussi
d'autres le voient peut-être un peu plus
raté qu'est ce que vous en pensez
écoutez bon encore une fois c'est une
compétition pour la tête d'un parti
l'imaginé pas à moi dans cette
trajectoire là je l'imaginais plutôt sur
la trajectoire des primaires c'est
compliqué pour lui c'est parce que je
dis henri guaino dit henri guaino de
l'effectif est compliquée et cetera
et effectivement je pense qu'il aurait
pu s'en passer il a choisi de le faire
il est parfaitement légitime et il a
tous ses atouts pour bien suivre
conquérir la présidence du parti voilà
mais c'est pas forcément en retour
réussi en tout cas mais en tout cas il
est évident que lorsque on est sur
l'aventin lorsqu'on a décidé de se
retirer et complot pour plonger en plus
dans une compétition qui oppose des
hommes donc pour la bataille pour la
conquête d'un parti c'est beaucoup
beaucoup plus compliqué c'est une
évidence
voilà d'aucuns disent que en dessous de
75 80 % la présidence de l'ump ça sera
déjà ça sera déjà co interprété comme un
mauvais résultat
les interprétations moi je m'en fiche
non non je sais pas quel jeu pas quel
est le seuil
je sais pas si c'est 70 72 69 68 bon peu
importe c'est de cet ordre là en tout
cas non je ne sais pas mais en tout cas
il est clair que en tout cas ce qui ce
qui est positif pour le p6 qu'une vraie
compétition une compétition d'abord pour
la présidence du parti et une
compétition aussi pour la primaire entre
nous c'est quand même positif que une
grande famille politique comme comme la
nôtre puisse aligner deux anciens
premiers ministres des hommes d'état
nicolas sarkozy ancien sans doute ancien
président de république
je veux dire que voilà abondance de
biens ne nuit pas au contraire mais vous
avez finalement leur destin pour
françois fillon comme celui qui a connu
françois hollande que monsieur 5% il a
disparu des écrans radars ce fillon
aujourd'hui et vous pensez qu'elle
viendra très fort je sais être le numéro
un ce que je dis c'est que les jeux sont
toujours ouverts je suis un homme de
fidélité
j'ai une proximité à la fois affectif
géographique intellectuelle aussi avec
ce que représente françois fillon et et
le jeu est très très ouvert très
franchement encore une fois il ya une
échéance qui le mois de décembre pour le
parti et puis ensuite il y aura d'autres
échéances pour les présidentielles et
donc les primaires donc vous vous avez
été dans votre histoire politique proche
de philippe de villiers
françois fillon maintenant et c'est
d'incarner une certaine forme de
thatchérisme à la française est-ce que
vous avez l'impression que ces deux
lignes qui sont assez compatibles ce
thatchérisme d'un côté et ce qu'est ce
que vous avez pu représenter un moment 1
500 militants no 90 d'ailleurs le je
récuse de mode de thatchérisme
je pense que quand on vit en france
aujourd'hui la france est au bord du
gouffre quand on vit dans un pays où
vous avez 50 7% de la dépense publique
vis-à-vis du pib la richesse vous êtes
nécessairement pour plus d'audace pour
l'esprit d'entreprise
vous êtes pour plus de liberté vous êtes
pour dc pour desserrer tous les carcans
et il se positionne de façon claire et
nette
parce que je pense encore une fois on
parlait tout à l'heure du gouvernement
ont parlé du budget je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut sortir du cadre
les américains ont une expression il dit
out of the box
mais si on reste dans cadre on est mort
et l'intérêt de françois fillon c'est
que il a creusé son sillon il creuse son
sillon
il a des propositions qui donne le là
d'ailleurs les propositions qu'il a
annoncées en matière d'économie en
matière budgétaire sont souvent des
propositions qui sont ensuite reprises
par d'autres challengers voyez pas le
plan mais justement il ya la
personnalité qui est importante vous
savez que dans la tradition un peu
gaullienne dans la tradition d'un
cinquième république
la présidentielle c'est la rencontre
d'un homme avec le peuple est donc bien
bien entendu que la personnalité c'est
quelque chose qui compte aussi mémé pour
moi qui ai toujours considéré que la
politique c'était d'abord des idées des
convictions
voilà le projet sera fondamental pour la
france c est ce que l'aune de cette
rentrée politique on n'a pas
l'impression que c'est plutôt françois
fillon et nicolas sarkozy qui alain
juppé nicolas sarkozy qui vont à la
rencontre du peuple alors que françois
fillon est peut-être un peu écarté de ce
duel
mais non parce que encore une fois trois
ans c'est très très long et que on est
d'abord sur une compétition pour le
parti et ensuite il y aura les primaires
tant que les jeux vous verrez les jeux
sont très très ouvert c'est la raison
pour laquelle je rappelais les petits
scores dans les sondages de françois
hollande
un an et demi avant avant j'en reviens
pas de déprime chez les fillonnistes non
mais non pas du tout parce que j'ai ce
que j'ai l'air des tribus non mais
cesser le combat
je veux dire c'est pas une question
d'écurie la france va mal moi j'aime la
france j'aime mon pays et je veux qu'ils
se portent mieux pas pas seulement pour
moi mais pour nos enfants pour les
futures générations et ça sera un choix
qui sera important je pense que si on
loupe les élections de 2017
le contrôle de la situation nous
échappera venue de mise et vous pensez
que le pouvoir sera ramassé en 2017
moi je pense que si ça compte écoutez
alors là vraiment m'a franchement
franchement j'espère que le suffrage
universel pourra mettre la gauche à
l'écart aujourd'hui on va dans le mur
tout le monde le dit toulousain les
français d'abord il souffre au mieux ou
au deuxième tour je comprends pas bien
votre nom ce que je veux dire c'est que
j'espère bien qu'il y aura une
alternance en 2017
qu'est-ce que ouvert françois hollande
vous pouvez le dire est ce qu il lui
même peut le dire ce qu'il peut le dire
est ce que ses ministres peuvent le dire
pour ça qu'il ya des zigzags décoiffe je
le disais tout à l'heure
donc non moi ce que j'espère c'est que
on aura une ligne qui sera une ligne en
rupture avec ce qui s'est fait de la
politique nationale depuis ces dernières
années
la rupture c'est peut-être aussi vous
parliez justement des formes de
personnalités de comportement lionel
tardy disait aujourd'hui me semble que
on ne pouvait pas répéter d'éviter les
finalistes aussi parce qu'on ne peut pas
forcément à la fois faire des cures
fritter propres exemplaires numériques
faire des conférences rémunéré comme le
fait par exemple aujourd'hui je crois
nicolas sarkozy à séoul et essayer de
s'engager au service de la france
non je tends du nom
nora drame non pas le débat a un
problème de rémunération de conférence
c'est vraiment pas le sujet le sujet
c'est la france
une représentation qui se font les
français nicolas sarkozy de quelqu'un
voilà qui franchement franchement c'est
pas sur ce sujet là que les français
feront leur choix
le choix sera de redresser la france ce
sera le rebond nationale
c'est encore temps ce sera très tard il
y aura des choix qui sont importants à
faire sur tous les sujets qu'on ait
évoqué sur l'indemnisation chômage sur
les 35 heures sur beaucoup d'autres
sujets sur l'école par exemple ils ce
sont ses choix qui devront décider du
gagnant et du perdant d'abord aux
primaires puis ensuite à l'élection
présidentielle lors de l'élection
présidentielle on peut lire sur le
premier tour avec la présence de marine
le pen
bien sûr c'est pour ça que je suis pour
les primaires
les primaires qui ne sont d'ailleurs
plus contesté si c'était le cas ça n'est
plus maintenant le cas désormais les
primaires c'est quand même le ticket
pour celui qui les gagnera au deuxième
tour parce que avec ce que l'on connaît
désormais des scores du front national
s'il n'y a pas de primaire ce sera un
encouragement à une pluralité de
candidatures à droite et au centre pour
le premier tour et alors on est sûr
d'avoir non seulement marine le pen au
deuxième tour mais peut-être aussi le
candidat de gauche
si la droite se présente de façon
fractionnée éparpillés vous en tant que
président du groupe ump vous allez
rester neutre vous avez dit dans dans
telle pour qu'elle le scrutin pour celui
la présidence de l'union justement où
j'ai pris j'ai pris un engagement au cdc
on est au sénat
je crois que la force du sénat c'est
l'indépendance et l'autonomie aussi bien
vis-à-vis de l'exécutif comme ceux
d'hier et ceux d'aujourd'hui que
vis-à-vis de notre famille il n'est pas
question je les dis que le groupe ump au
sénat se transforme en succursale soit
une courroie de transmission il y avait
des tentations via il ya il doit y avoir
effectivement une coopération
elle sera sans ambiguïté et sera franche
active mais je suivrai la ligne de
l'indépendance et pour la suivre je
serai le garant de l'unité et pour être
le garant je me suis engagé
justement cette neutralité dans le
premier temps de l'élection du président
ce qui n'exclut pas qu'ensuite vous
puissiez exprimé une préférence pour la
primaire oui mais je ferai très très
attention je ferai très attention les
gens me connaissent ils savent de
fidélité je ferai très attention à ne
pas tirer à lier le groupe
encore une fois si on veut avoir un
sénat qui se redresse il faut que le
premier groupe politique puisse être
unis pour être fort c'est la condition
du redressement aussi du bicamérisme bon
il ya une question qui divise dans le
groupe politique sélection du mariage
pour tous alors peut-être pas dans le
groupe mais en tout cas l'ump
certains sont pour un débat nicolas
sarkozy d'autres sont pour l'abrogation
pendant que laurent wauquiez
françois fillon si je me trompe pas
comme alain juppé n'envisage pas de
l'abroger une réécriture ils sont
prononcés pour une réécriture ça c'est
de la sémantique pour réécrire faut
abroger
moi je suis favorable à l'orgasme voilà
donc j'ai porté au sénat
la motion référendaire on pourrait
déduire soumettre aux français par
référendum un choix voilà je crois que
il faut avoir un immense respect pour
les êtres qui souhaite consacrer leur
amour on peut le faire avec une union
civile
on a différentes formules pour le faire
juridiquement en revanche le problème de
la filiation
le problème de l'adoption des bouches
tôt ou tard on le voit aujourd'hui sur
la pma et sur la gpa il en est pas
question
le groupe est pas ce que dit le
gouvernement il n'en est pas question
attendez il ya une hypocrisie une
hypocrisie sans nom
1 le gouvernement ne fait pas appel de
la décision de la cour européenne devra
de l'homme de le gouvernement il ya
encore quelques semaines à 300 mètres de
l'assemblée ça fait la troisième fois en
un an et demi une société américaine et
est en tain de vente des services pour
louer le ventre de femme sans doute
nécessiteuses à des couples français
c'est interdit c'est inacceptable parce
que c'est la marchandisation du corps
c'est inacceptable juridiquement parce
que c'est interdit
pourquoi pourquoi madame taubira
pourquoi le parquet ne poursuit pas ces
sociétés donc on aimait bien le trouver
un avenir ces enfants qui naissent pour
par exemple pourquoi pourquoi des
sociétés américaines c'est la troisième
fois en peu de temps violent la loi en
france proposent par les eaux grecques
non non non c'est faux il propose avec
comme des bestiaux en présentant des
femmes
vous choisissez blondes brunes et cetera
exactement comme des bestiaux est ce que
ça vous révoltent pas eh bien moi ça me
révolte et sur mon pays j'entends que la
loi soit respectée justement la question
que je posais c'est on ne comprend pas
forcément quelle va être la position de
l'ump en 2017 si jamais l arrivée au
pouvoir sur ce sujet à benoît on est
très clair moi je souhaite qu'il y ait
une abrogation qui est un référendum et
qui fait que je viens de les couples
peut pas démarrer image et sûr que et
récemment une exceptionnelle sera pas
rétroactif
bien sûr ça ne sera pas rétroactif le
problème si vous voulez c'est exactement
ça l'est souvent vous avec le pacs les
ébène goodyear il ya le pack ira pas le
mariage ensuite introduira il ya le
mariage mais il n'y aura pas la gpa il y
aura pas les pme
le problème c'est qu'au nom de l'égalité
conçu comme une stricte un strict
égalitarisme on voit bien que ce qu'ont
les couples de femmes
les coupes des hommes le veulent et ça
nous entraîne très vite alors il faut
mettre
il faut mettre des limites c'est tout je
reviens d'un mois sur les enfants
puisque sur public sénat jacques toubon
le nouveau défenseur des droits a
expliqué qu'il fallait effectivement
offrir un cadre et un statut aux enfants
mais menées illégalement en nommant
cadre il leur donner des papiers une
reconnaissance
il y un cadre juridique l'état civil oui
mais il y un cadre juridique les ceux
qui prétendent que aujourd'hui ces
enfants sont en dehors du droit se
trompe il y à un cadre maintenant alors
leur donner des papiers dont les
voitures là qu'il allait reconnaître et
à 18 ans ils vont ils choisiront d'être
il n'ya pas il n'y a pas de souci ils se
sont pas ces personnes là ces jeunes
enfants sont pas en dehors du droit
en revanche admettre et régularisés si
j'ose dire une infraction à la loi
un détournement de ce qu'on appelle de
l'ordre public moi je n'y suis pas
favorable à accor pour être clair on il
ya une ligne on s'y tient voilà après on
peut d'abord que vous habitez pour
l'abrogation on l'a compris on reviendra
d'ailleurs avec perrine sur certaines de
vos convictions à qui vous motive dans
ce débat ces accords bruno retailleau
merci guillaume puisqu'on va parler un
peu plus de vous maintenant également de
ce que vous comptez faire est ce que
vous proposez comme réforme pour le
sénat juste après ce portrait donc que
dresse sandra cerqueira
on le dit très attaché à sa terre
vendéenne
sur les cinq hectares qui entoure sa
maison bruno retailleau élèves une
véritable petite basse cour c'est un élu
des territoires une carte sur laquelle
il a joué pour prendre la tête de l'ump
au sénat alors qu'il n'est encarté que
depuis deux ans un tour de force pour
cet inconnu du grand public
son objectif redorer l'image d'un sénat
mise à mal être fillonniste a aussi dû
jouer en sa faveur
il y avait une véritable volonté de nos
collègues de conserver l'indépendance du
groupe au sénat
et c'est vrai que la candidature du
rocher n 2 roger karoutchi a peut-être
pu apparaître comme étant trop liée à
l'élection interne à la tête de l'ump je
pense que ça a joué
mais la volonté de renouvellement a
certainement été le critère prépondérant
jusque là bruno retailleau a effectué sa
carrière au mpf le mouvement pour la
france et dans l'ombre de philippe de
villiers qui en a fait son bras droit au
conseil général de vendée un passé
villiéristes qui lui colle à la peau
même si en 2009 c'est la rupture avec
son mentor philippe de villiers refuse
que bruno retailleau intègre le
gouvernement fillon
c'était pour lui quand même une histoire
d'honneur au moment où
le discours devenait trop extrémiste
bruno retailleau qui a voulu garder
justement cette ligne de conduite de
cette objectivité a compris que il
fallait aussi que qu'ils puissent je
veux dire jouer sa propre mais le
s'émanciper pour continuer raconté en
politique
même chez les socialistes bruno
retailleau a le vent en poupe
certains lui prédisent même un destin
national à l'intérieur de ma commission
pendant trois ans je trouve quelqu'un
d'ouvert et de compétent et de
travailleurs avec ça ou vous avez un bon
profil
le message qui lui a été envoyé par le
groupe bnp est une reconnaissance de ses
compétences anti mariage pour tous les
positions dites conservatrice du
sénateur de vendée dérange pour esther
benbassa la droite se radicalise au
sénat avec l'élection de bruno
retailleau des prises de position de
plus en plus à droite qui vont un petit
peu dans le sens de plaire
la droite
de marine le pen d'aller dans ce sens
plutôt que dans un sens les d'ouverture
et de compréhension ça m'inquiète mais
loin des sujets polémiques
bruno retailleau a choisi pour commencer
de s'attaquer à la fraude fiscale des
parlementaires un sujet plutôt
consensuel voilà pas forcément le même
regard vous allez peut-être tentés
d'essayer de rassurer esther benbassa
avec qui parfois vous avez dit
mais c'est vrai ça va déjà sur le nouvel
organigramme du sénat y ait une élection
qui a été constestée c'est celle du
sénateur ump alain milon à la tête de la
commission des affaires sociales alain
millot qui avaient pris position dans un
rapport pour un encadrement de la gpa en
france est ce que vous êtes de ceux qui
contestent ses positions donc est ce qu
il a toute sa place à la tête de la
commission des affaires sociales du
sénat
bien sûr bien sûr c'est un très bon
spécialiste notamment des questions
sociales il a montré d'ailleurs il ya eu
qu'un seul candidat
1 il n'a pas été élu contre quelqu'un
d'autre un c'était une des commissions
où il y avait un seul candidat donc il
ya pas eu d'élection parce que ses
collègues lui ont fait confiance
voilà simplement alain milon sur un
service de questions peut avoir des
positions personnelles mais il y aura la
position du groupe qui très
majoritairement au moment du mariage
pour tous à 97 18 % a été clair et il
n'a pas souhaité voter le mariage pour
tous et tous je pense que là aussi ça ne
correspond pas peut-être à ce qu'on
attend de nous en termes de fermeture
cet arabe ce que j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure mais il ya des positions qui
peuvent être parfois individuel chacun
sa liberté de conscience
chacun son parcours personnel que je
respecte beaucoup en revanche dès lors
qu'il faut trancher
il ya une cohérence il ya eu ni du
groupe et puis voilà c'est tout il ya
aucun sujet j'ai vu que c'était une
question débattue mais y'a pas n'y a pas
de signal si j'ose dire avec
à la mi longue quitte donc un expérience
spécialisée des questions sociales par
ailleurs les médecins il connaît son
sujet alors c'est vrai que sur toutes
ces questions la gpa pma les familles
homosexuelles ou non tout le monde se
pose des questions y compris l'église
j'imagine que vous suivez un peu ce qui
se passe à rome autour du pape françois
le synode sur la famille
le compte rendu du rapport d'étape
montre une évolution de la part de
l'église qui insiste notamment en
matière de gps sur le droit des petits
droit qui prime sur celui des adultes
la réflexion l'église évoluer ce que ça
va dans le bon sens selon vous et je
vous savez je suis pas théologie est
donc ne me suis pas évêques si ça peut
vous rassurer
on me demandait sa position sur des
sujets théologie président moi je trouve
que je vous intéresse un shoot je trouve
que les positions du pape françois vont
dans le bon sens je pense que la
préférence notamment pour les fragiles
pour les pauvres pour ceux qui sont
blessés de la vie qui avait aussi
exprimé à l'époque jean paul 2 c'est
important le fait qu'ils puissent faire
avancer les positions moi je loin dans
ses réformes sociétales
non moi je n'en je trouve que c'est
plutôt positif il convoque un synode
on en parle ce sera tranché moi je
trouve que au contraire je trouve c'est
une façon plutôt moderne et généreuse de
conduire sexuelle au divorce et les
questions qui divisent en oui mais moi
ça moi franchement ça ne choque pas
encore une fois lorsqu'on est amené je
pense qu'il ya il ya deux choses je
crois qu'il faut respecter infiniment
chaque être humain quel que soit son
choix quel que soit son inclinaison ces
voix là il ya aucun sujet de ce point de
vue là après quand on est responsable
public comme moi on doit prendre on fait
des choix
il m'arrive pour tous pour moi ça posait
cette question d'affiliation de
l'adoption qui devait tout ou tard
débouché sur la gpa la pma voilà c'est
tout après chacun justement exprime ses
convictions mais moi je trouve que ce
que souhaitent les français se sont pas
des hommes politiques hors sol sans
conviction c'est qu'on a l'intelligence
d'affirmer des convictions tout en
respectant toujours les adversaires les
personnes c'est toujours été mon cas
voilà on peut avoir une sorte de fermeté
dans la conviction et
de respect envers go quand on l'entend
que non seulement beaucoup de télé non
je parle j'écoute et moi je dis non moi
je suis je suis ouvert voilà
franchement je ne m'amuse pas ce genre
de choses je pense que c'est le degré
zéro de la politique donc je préfère
débattre sur des arguments plutôt que de
condamner tel ou tel en fonction de ses
positions je crois que on est dans une
démocratie ce qui est important c'est
que chacun puisse argumenté est-ce que
ici au sénat dans tous les débats qu'on
a pu avoir
on a pu me faire le reproche d'une pas
argumenter mes positions je pense pas
que je passe pour quelqu'un qui ne sache
pas argumenter ses positions alors
maintenant vous allez argumenté sur ce
que vous voulez faire à la tête du
groupe ump
ici au sénat vous entendez un carnet
avec d'autres le renouveau le nouveau
cema alors c'est vrai qu'après des des
semaines de senna bashing avant les
élections au sénat savoir c'est la
crédibilité voire même parfois la
légitimité de la haute assemblée a été
entamée quelles réformes
vous voulez faire très rapidement ici au
sénat pour redorer l'image de la haute
assemblée pour le sauver oui je veux moi
je pense que on célèbre le 100e
anniversaire vous savez de la guerre
14-18 et et après que valérie avait eu
cette phrase en disant voilà nous savons
désormais que les civilisations sont
mortelles et bien les institutions sont
aussi mortelle simplement ce que je veux
dire aux français ce qu'ils nous
écoutent peut-être à l'instant c'est que
dans un moment difficile que traverse la
france
il ya une chose qui tient ses les
institutions qui a fondé le général de
gaulle de la vème république
est ce que je veux dire c'est que le
bicamérisme c'est fondamental pourquoi
c'est fondamental parce que c'est une
réponse je trouve à deux mots qui sont
importants on légifère trop sous
l'émotion clémenceau disait que le sénat
c'est le recul c'est le temps de la
réflexion on en a besoin pour avoir
moins de lois et des lois mieux fait et
ensuite on a besoin d'un territoire
l'histoire quand on voit tous les
gouvernements qui utilisent de plus en
plus les prévenir et bien c'était rien
eh bien c'était supprimer le sénat
qu'est-ce qui se passera une seule
lecture à l'assemblée nationale sous
l'émotion
sous la pression médiatique une lecture
politicienne tandis qu' il y aura plus
de loi beaucoup plus de loi beaucoup
plus mal fait et ensuite le deuxième
avantage du sénat c'est la france des
territoires
or un des problèmes français c'est la
phrase
territoriales on voit bien qu'il ya deux
france qui sont en train de diverger la
france connectée à la mondialisation et
la france des invisibles des oubliés je
pense que le sénat peut rapprocher ces
deux france la voilà c'est pour ça que
je crois que le sénat est important il
est moderne d'avancé sur l'intérêt du
bicamérisme que nous parle t'on jours a
effectivement beaucoup ici mais sur les
réformes
concrètement écouter les premières
choses j'ai plaidé pour la carte du
rajeunissement du renouvellement je
pense que conseillez vous à un accent
gpd aussi pour la carte du la
féminisation
par exemple un un des deux postes qui
nous était celle de l'ump
je les réserve et pour une femme
s'appelle debré a été brillamment élu et
j'en félicite enfin si oui alors les
réformes je pense que il faut que celle
d'un se réforme notamment un certain
nombre il faut plus de transparence plus
édité il ya la réserve parlementaire sur
les comptes des groupes politiques
on sait qu'il ya eu des problèmes autour
de certains comptes de l'uimm et bien je
pense que la certification des comptes
c'est une exigence absolument les verts
parlementaire la version non je pense
que les communes les petites communes au
moment où l'état est en train de baisser
ses notations en ont besoin simplement
il faut pas qu'il y ait une différence
de traitement ne soit pas expliqué donc
il faut la transparence et il faut en
même temps les quitter et je
m'appliquerai avant la fin d'année à
faire avec gérard larcher cette réforme
là donc ce sont des choses concrètes il
faut aussi sortir le sénat de paris
beaucoup plus souvent et donc comment
voulez vous verrez sortir mais c'est
notre pari et vous savez oui -2 -2 grand
messe par exemple les assises de la
ruralité soutenait il ya deux ans les
états généraux de la démocratie
territoriale les grands vases qui vaut
cher et finissent par quoi pas par rien
du tout bien je pense qu'on doit aller
sur le terrain quand il ya eu le drame
xynthia un exemple on a créé avec gérard
larcher une mission d'information
il y avait aussi une mission de députés
les sénateurs se sont rendus du premier
sur le terrain et je vous assure qu'on a
fait un excellent travail bien il faut
être
il faut que senna soit en prise avec le
quotidien en même temps tout en ayant
cette ce recul cette hauteur de vue
c'est fondamental
bruno retailleau qu'est ce qui vous
reste de votre aventure aux côtés de
philippe de villiers a dû vous souvenir
bien celui du genou bien sûr j'étais 25
ans metteur en scène tout à fait
bénévole mais c'est une grande réussite
française qu'il faut saluer voilà chez
c'est tout ça fait partie
ça fait partie du passé il ya eu des
divergences avec la milliardaire
il ya eu des divergences bien avant 2009
voilà et c'est voilà c'est ce qui m'a
écarté progressivement de philippe de
villiers
la mise en scène qui est maintenant
vendu en russie avec des déclarations
parfois un peu surprenante de philippe
de villiers sur poutine
j'échangerais volontiers hollande plus
sarkozy contre poutine fait partie des
choses qui vont c'est ce qu'ils nous ont
séparés
voilà sept cette expression là est en
elle même une partie de l'explication
dernière question peut-être autour de
journal guérini qui a été réélu
confortablement ici cemac est ce que
vous inspire ce spectacle de ce sénateur
confortablement donc réélu et devant la
justice dix jours après il aura rendre
des comptes devant la justice moi je
pense que la présomption d'innocence
vaut pour tout le monde
les élus sont pas au dessus des lois les
élus ne sont pas en dessous des lois
c'est tout il ya une élection elle et
j'imagine démocratique s'est déroulé
n'est pas contestée est donc désormais
c'est le temps de la justice
il faut que la justice aille à son terme
je pense que je suis un partisan des
institutions fortes
l'asus eee la justice et notre
institution c'est notre bien commun mais
il faut attention de ne pas juger avant
les juges c'est le juge
ils doivent et vous voulez monsieur
propre que vous l'avez plus loin que les
mesures de transparence qui ont été
annoncées par le chef de l'état a
alimenté d'ailleurs pour dire leur
rapport des parlementaires à leur
dossier fiscal
écoutez sandra cerqueira la main que
jamais d'un mot bien sûr un mousqueton
nous avons déposé j'ai déposé plusieurs
sénateurs de l'ump avec moi une
proposition de loi sur la sphère
thévenoud parce qu'il en a marre
vous savez bien qu'à chaque fois qu'il
ya un parlementaire qui se trouve pris
sous les feux des projecteurs pour avoir
commis non pas des indélicatesses mais
des fautes extrêmement grave
ça rejaillit sur nos institutions sur
nous mêmes j'entendais des déclarations
qu'il présidait
certificat et bien moi j'ai versé cette
proposition de loi
j'en ai marre des déclarations je
souhaite qu'on avance donc les choses
sont très simples il faudra indiquer sur
l'honneur qui a pas de soucis ce sera
transmis à l'autorité pour la
transparence de la vie politique qui
transmettra s'il ya un problème je pense
qu'on vote la loi on voit la loi de
finances convoque l'impôt la moindre des
choses c'est de d'être vis-à-vis de
cette norme qui concerne tous les
français en parfaite régularité
il s'agit pas d'une étourderie c'est
vraiment quand il ya les écarts
importants aux france a besoin de non
déclaration quelques mois j'ai pensé à
monsieur balkany aussi je pense à tous
ceux qui ne respectent pas dans des
conditions exorbitantes les déclarations
est en réalité le droit commun voilà
fabien merci monsieur retailleau merci
d'avoir été avec no mercy perrine
bonsoir à tous et à très vite